hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear this is my movie review series
this is really pissing me off because i
recorded this entire video already
but when i went to edit it i discovered
that uh it had not recorded any audio so
this is the second time that i'm going
through this so
please bear with me
okay so the movie i'm talking about
today is another one that i had been
wanting to see for a really long time
another one that kind of got a lot of
buzz around when it came out at the
festivals and all that stuff and this is
another one that is currently streaming
on hulu at least as of this recording so
if you want to watch it you can this is
a movie called sensor
so those who grew up in the uk in the
early to mid 1980s will no doubt
remember the whole
video nasties kerfuffle
now obviously i grew up in the united
states uh but i was a kid during that
same era i was like a tween or teenager
during the early 80s
and i was also a total anglophile uh and
i was a big horror fan so i read a lot
about stuff that was going on in the uk
because i was really into british music
and stuff like that
so i was pretty aware of all of the
crazy [ __ ] that was going on with the
whole video nasty thing if you don't
know what that is if you're too young to
remember anything like that there was a
time in the early to mid 1980s when
largely like um conservative politicians
uh you know kind of more conservative
newspapers and media and stuff like that
were basically uh trying to either they
actually believed or they were trying to
convince everybody else that all of the
problems that were going on in the uk at
the time with like rising unemployment
and crime and things like that could
pretty much be blamed on cory horror
movies so you had you know figures like
mary whitehouse and you know margaret
thatcher was the prime minister and
stuff like that and they were just kind
of decrying all this filth all these
movies that were just like turning
people into violent degenerates and [ __ ]
like that
blaming everything you know that was
going wrong in the uk pretty much
like on this handful of essentially
harmless splatter flicks right
so you even had like a number of horror
films i believe there's there's a list
on wikipedia i think the list of like
banned outright was like 31 or 34 films
or something like that but there were
different ones like of different tiers
like of how much they got cut or you
know whatever but like i said some of
them were banned and it was actually
like illegal to sell them
so as ridiculous as it sounds to younger
people nowadays and indeed it sounded
ridiculous to me even back then in the
early 1980s like how stupid this was and
i was a kid back then you could
legitimately literally be sent to prison
in the uk
if you ran a video store and you
happened to stock like the driller
killer or cannibal holocaust or i spit
on your grave or something like that
like under the counter and would like
rent it to people on the dl like they
could absolutely come into your video
store and raid it
um and take you to jail and [ __ ] like
that which is
idiotic uh to think that just like some
crappy ass horror movie is actually
responsible for what is obviously caused
by
larger socioeconomic issues which i
don't think is controversial to say in
the slightest but here we are everybody
likes simple solutions so horror movies
that that was an easy thing to blame
so
this is kind of like the background uh
of what the movie sensor is so this was
co-written and directed by a welsh woman
named prano bailey bond
and uh this is her first film
so the movie is kind of set during this
big cultural upheaval of the early to
mid 1980s with a particular focus on
video nasties but there's also like a
background in other things like all the
strikes and unemployment and stuff like
that as i mentioned and this is actually
like a great setting for a horror movie
it's i'm really like kind of ripe with
possibilities so this movie premiered at
sundance in 2021 and ended up winning
the melee door which is kind of
essentially like the top prize for the
best european like genre of film
um also the well-known british film
critic mark carmode also a big fan of
this uh he picked it as his movie of the
week like the week that it came out and
gave it like five out of five stars and
i'm gonna have to side with him on this
one i i really did like this one a lot
it's a very very bold uh film especially
if like for a feature first feature film
and it's uh pretty brilliant i just had
a really good time with this one
so the movie centers on this woman named
enid played by niamh algar now she's
quite young
but she's real prim like you know she's
always has those granny blouses that are
all kind of like buttoned all the way to
the neck um kind of like sensible slacks
like flat shoes her hair is always like
pulled back in a bun she's got like the
reading glasses with like the granny
chain and all that kind of [ __ ] so she
works for the bbfc the british board of
film classification
so her job essentially it's not just her
there's several other sensors there as
well
but their job is to just sit around
and screen you know the grisliest horror
films imaginable and then they type up
recommendations about
what scenes should be cut out and
you know once the scenes are cut out um
you know what rating is it going to get
or should we just ban this one out right
because it's irredeemable you know if we
cut everything out there won't be
anything left or whatever so that's kind
of what she does she just watches the
films and then gives her recommendations
and then that's what they do
so
interestingly it's kind of like across
the board some of the um because most of
the other sensors are male there is one
other woman that she works with and that
woman seems to be like a little bit more
affected by the content of the films
particularly like you know kind of rape
scenes and stuff like that
but enid despite her being like kind of
uptight
seeming the content of films doesn't
really seem to bother her as much as
maybe some of the other ones
and this is mostly because she is like
absolutely laser focused on what she
calls
getting it right like she wants to do
the editing she wants to cut out exactly
what needs to be cut out and that's
gonna just like
be perfect and solve everything i mean
basically
she seems to wholeheartedly believe
that just
you know for example trimming out oh
there's a bloody eye gouging scene over
here or a brutal rape scene over there
and we just trim those out and that's
gonna stave off like complete societal
breakdown right she thinks that she's
she genuinely seems to feel like she's
protecting the population by preventing
them from watching this kind of like
manufactured violence right
now despite enid being like very very
prickish
she's still a really sympathetic
character
even though it doesn't sound like it on
paper but she does actually come across
as very sympathetic
in the film probably because you can
tell pretty much from right away that
her prissiness is sort of stemming
from some past trauma or some emotional
repression that she has going on so we
find out what's going on with that like
not too long into the film
there's a scene where she goes uh and
has dinner with her parents now you can
tell
even before they are in the same room
together that there's like a lot of
tension between them they're not hostile
toward one another but you can tell they
don't really talk to one another it's
just like very awkward
so she goes to this dinner and her
parents hand her a death certificate
which seems ominous but wait
it turns out
that enid when she was a kid like a long
time ago
she had a little sister named nina
nina went missing when she was seven
years old
now enid was there when it happened so
this is something like they don't i
don't think they say like exactly when
it was um but since nina was seven and
it's like now it seems like it was like
20 years or something like that so i'm
gonna say it's something like 20 years
ago so enid was with her when it
happened they were playing together in
the woods but it seems as though she has
blocked out
most of the memory of what exactly
happened on that day that her sister
disappeared you do see kind of like
flashes of it but it doesn't really like
say exactly what happened it's just kind
of like her quick like brief perceptions
of or memories of it
now enid um as you probably would does
blame herself uh for her sister's
disappearance um you know i could have
done more or you know whatever it is
and i will say that her dad seems to
kind of low-key blame her as well not so
much her mom but it doesn't really come
out much but there is that is probably
like contributing a lot to like the
awkwardness like in their relationship
so probably because of this
enid has chosen to believe
that nina is still alive somewhere
whereas her parents have pretty much
come to the sad conclusion
that nina is probably dead they're like
well if she was alive um we would have
found her by now she would have come
back she would have contacted us by now
she must be dead and we had this death
certificate issued we just want closure
and you know we just want to move on
like as a family it's like you know it
was a long time ago it's terrible it's
sad but you know we just need to like
live our own lives now
however
enid sees this as kind of like a
betrayal or like a slap in the face um
so it does
seem that her already strained
relationship with her parents uh you
know gets a lot more
like sours a lot more after that
so there's that going on
it also doesn't help uh that she's run
into a kind of a big problem at work now
uh she is acknowledged like among her
colleagues that she is very very good at
her job she's very thorough but her
co-workers kind of feel like maybe maybe
she takes this whole censoring thing
just a little bit too seriously like she
gets too too into it
uh behind her back at least one of them
calls her little miss perfect because
she kind of overhears like two of the
guys talking in the break room or
whatever
but uh despite
her perceived like up tightness
it turns out that her
and one of her more easygoing co-workers
had previously passed a film called
deranged now i'm assuming that they're
talking about the real film deranged
which
we talked about on this channel
just not just a few weeks ago uh which
came out in 1974 robert's blossom was in
it and it's loosely based on you know ed
gain the murderer and grave robber so
i'm assuming that that's the movie that
they're talking about
so uh so her and the co-worker had
passed this movie deranged with only
minimal cuts
and it so happened that one of the
scenes that they left in the movie
intact showed a man eating someone's
face
it further turns out that very recently
there has been a real crime that has
occurred in britain
in which a man killed his wife
ate her face
and then drove to his kid's school and
shot both of his children
the perpetrator claims he does not
remember committing this horrific act so
they end up calling him the amnesiac
killer or whatever it is
but he does helpfully tell the police
that i'm pretty sure i watched this
movie deranged shortly before doing it
so you know which kind of like fuels
everyone's just go oh my god a movie
like made him do it you know what i mean
so there's that so there's like a media
circus kind of like ensues and it turns
out that somebody leaked the information
that enid was one of the sensors that
passed the film with that scene uncut
so she starts getting threatening phone
calls and you know unwanted tabloid
attention like they start kind of
following around and taking pictures
over and [ __ ] like that
so there's also that going on
so in the midst of all this stress
enid and yet another one of her
co-workers
kind of get their latest film that
they're going to be reviewing
the producer brings it um so this is an
older movie and it's called don't go in
the church
and it's directed by this sort of like
shadowy cult filmmaker by the name of
frederick north who's a little bit um
he's kind of well known like in
underground film circles
so the first scene of don't go in the
church
ends up bearing an uh uncomfortable
resemblance to what enid remembers about
the day her sister nina disappeared enid
like
like starts freaking out like looking at
like watching it she's like so she
starts to become convinced that the guy
who made the film has to know something
about where her missing sister is or
what happened to nina
so then she manages to get her hands on
one of frederick north's newer films
like she goes to this kind of corner
shop and
the guy there has like some illicit [ __ ]
that he's not like some band films he's
not supposed to have and he keeps him
under the counter but he's willing to
like rent him to people that he knows
like because he knows he's not going to
get knarked on but she comes in asking
him like for frederick northfilms and
he's like look babe i don't know you and
i don't have any of those what are you
talking about you know what i mean
because you could totally get arrested
right but because she's a censor and
because she's seen all this all the gory
movies she's able to look kind of like
leverage that knowledge into saying yeah
look i'm just a horror movie fan i know
how i look but you know i'm into that
kind of stuff so he's like okay well
don't tell anybody i got this so he
gives her
a videotape of a newer frederick north
film which is called asunder
so she takes it home and watches it this
movie features an actress named alice
lee
and while enid is watching the movie
she's like watching this actress and
she's kind of like kept keeps rewinding
and feels and then she freeze frames on
the woman's face and she becomes
convinced because of how this woman
looks like her eyes and her red hair and
stuff like that she's like that is my
sister nina
so she
extrapolates
that the filmmaker because he had made
don't go in the church like a long time
ago which
mirrors exactly what she remembers of
the situation in which nina disappeared
like the same location in like a similar
situation she's like this filmmaker
must be the guy that took her like he
abducted her and now he's making her be
in these exploitative films and she
slowly becomes consumed by this
idea
so
overall i mean this is a great movie i
was like really really entertained it's
interesting because it starts out
as
sort of like a pretty standard
i don't want to say it's like buttoned
up but it's it's kind of like follows
the arc of the enid character so it's
very kind of like
staid and traditional at the beginning
but then
it just gets wilder and wilder as enid's
sort of like tenuous hold on sanity like
starts slipping away i especially too
like how this isn't a black comedy but
it does have
some real sly
satire in it of the whole video nasty
phenomenon because one of the things
that always bothered me about that whole
debacle
is sort of like the hypocrisy
behind
these sensors
saying well
we can sit all day and watch the sickest
horror movies ever made and somehow not
be affected and then but we can't let
the public see it or they'll all turn
into like crazed maniacs and i'm like
well so they're kind of like saying that
well that makes them better and i know
that particularly in britain there was
like a class kind of thing going on
behind it too because like oh those poor
people or those working class people
they can't handle like seeing this fake
gore these these movies it'll turn them
into animals but it's like you know us
with our university educations or
whatever the hell um we can sit here and
watch it and like watch it and be
detached and we are kind of qualified to
like tell other people what they can
handle and what they can't because you
would think if their whole premise
that watching this kind of stuff makes
you
more violent or makes you want to act
out like what you see in the movie then
you would think that all the sensors
would be like serial killers because
they just sit there all day and like
watch the [ __ ] and probably multiple
times because they have to sit there and
like rewind through it and be like oh
yeah we need to cut that little bit out
and [ __ ] like that so they probably like
watch these [ __ ] eye gougings and
rapes and all just all day [ __ ] long
and think about it all day [ __ ] long
and you would think that if that premise
was true then they would be like the
worst defenders they would be serial
killers because that's all they do is
sit there and watch it like all day long
at their job um obviously that doesn't
happen so again their whole entire
premise is flawed which to me like i
said seems very hypocritical so the
movie does kind of it's not real
heavy-handed with that point but there
is like a lot of a little bit of like
satirical things sort of about that and
i do kind of like the way that inverts
the sort of sensor character into like
maybe i don't know if i i don't know if
i want to say it's like it's something
you don't expect but i do kind of like
the way that it plays with her character
in that way in that sort of um you know
in that sort of context you know what
i'm saying
um i also like how the movie has and
this is even on the movie poster i think
because the movie poster has a tagline
like um you can't edit reality or
something like that so the movie also
has kind of a theme of
talking about our own memories and our
own past traumas and how
our brains tend to like edit events to
remember things the way we would rather
remember them maybe
rather than how they actually happened
so the final kind of sequence of censor
really kind of like drives this theme
home i think um because by that point
enid has pretty much fully embraced the
idea that all she has to do is
trim out like bits of her memories or
bits of her life or whatever that she
finds like either inconvenient or
dangerous or unsavory or whatever and if
she just does that then like all the
problems in the world will magically go
away you know what i mean so it's kind
of like as i said it's not funny but it
does have like a satirical sort of like
edge to it in that way where it's just
showing the ridiculousness like of the
hypocrisy of thinking just just cutting
a couple seconds of film out here and
there is going to like cause all the
crime and britain to go away and stuff
like that because she does actually seem
to believe that but she's off she's
obviously also got like some uh big
problems
so gonna say love the lead performance
in this by niamh algar like i said it
was
you know it was kind of like a hard roll
to pull off because on paper um you know
enid sounds like a very unlikable or
like an insufferable character but she
absolutely is not she actually comes
across like very very sympathetic um and
you can kind of understand where she's
coming from even as she kind of like
starts losing the plot like later on in
the movie also some uh other great
british actors that you will probably
recognize in this as well and like some
supporting roles got michael smiley in
this who was in kill list he was also in
a field in england uh which both of
those i've reviewed um also nicholas
burns is in this he was in the world's
end
so this is just a great i mean
especially for our first
feature film uh this is just a fantastic
movie it's very clever uh very ambitious
and i think that she really pulled it
off and it's really like a great kind of
look into this sort of like tumultuous
time in history which sort of focused on
specifically the video nasty thing and
the whole censorship thing of horror in
particular uh but also with a bigger
backdrop of you know the kind of
socioeconomic uh you know kind of uh
upheavals that were going on in the uk
at that time um also kind of goes a
little bit into
addressing maybe like the dangers of
repressing your negative emotions and
maybe kind of like the importance of
having something like a healthy outlet
like horror movies for example um in
which you can explore your dark sides
like in a safe kind of way so if you've
seen sensor uh or if you would like to
see it let me know in the comments and
we'll have a discussion about it as i
said it's streaming on hulu at the
moment uh at least as of this recording
and i'm sure it's streaming elsewhere as
well but let me know what you thought
about it in the comments and that will
do it for this flickers of fear i will
see you guys on the next one
bye